más problemas legales para Donald Trump
y también para su familia después de que
la fiscal general de Nueva York Leticia
James presentará una demanda civil por
sobrevalorar sus activos y patrimonio
exigimos a Trump y a su organización que
se deshagan de los beneficios
financieros obtenidos a través de las
prácticas fraudulentas persistentes
estimados en al menos 250 millones de
dólares
según la fiscalía Donald Trump y la
empresa Trump organization infló Su
riqueza en miles de millones para
obtener condiciones más favorables para
sus transacciones como tasas de interés
más bajas y seguros más baratos una
denuncia además de 200 páginas en la que
también figuran tres hijos de Trump
Donald Trump Junior Eric Trump e ivanka
Trump así como los ejecutivos de la
empresa acusaciones que Trump ha negado
de plano acosando a la fiscal negra de
racismo otra casa de brujas por parte
una fiscal general racista letillas
James que fracasó en su carrera para
gobernadora obteniendo un apoyo casi
nulo del público este es uno de los
muchos entramados legales que se
amontonan sobre su figura como la
investigación penal a por su acción
contra las elecciones presidenciales del
2020 o la investigación Federal sobre la
posesión de registros presidenciales
clasificados la fiscal James Lleva más
de tres años investigando la empresa de
Trump y cuenta con Fuentes cercanas al
ex presidente
Fue llamado a testificar el 10 de agosto
cuando se acogió más de 400 veces a su
derecho de no autoincriminarse negando
todos los cargos